I don't I don't know how it's to not do
that subway FBA learning Jackson
Boulevard
[Music]
[Music]
we're all just out here in New York City
just live and living the life look like
a big nose neanderthal you look like you
deserve to be to be taking up the space
that you're taking up you're not
apologetic for existence
like a child
loud New York the trades are very loud
very loud
big
those just stare at the camera pretend
it's not there and have a normal cover
okay so the probably world just [ __ ]
each other's cars
[Music]
Wow a box
are you a boxer or antibac sir
kiss me and backstage what are you Irish
of accident I mean we're all Irish to
some degree Irish is the state of mind
hey can you scoot your asses over
Oh
the pad what makes you so quiet and
introverted do you think that you're so
insecure and you've learned to
disassociate because as a child you're
parented yell
yeah nothing like a woman
where's their favorite comedians
walk the line between IG and real I mean
even the subscriber to my podcasts right
now you want to keep being honest Grand
Central for 30 minutes
central is beautiful people travel from
all over the world and see a have you
been in the middle with that really no
one's gonna be there right
we can roll around
just burns away circus
[Music]
No
my mother
podcaster you may be on a podcast
[Music]
Nastasia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here with Pat Smith it's a known
Trump supporter
it's got interesting perspectives so
they were very wrong it's great yeah
doesn't believe in racism against
minorities I think that's just made up
so that's sort of the kind of person I'm
dealing with tonight just look this way
dinner this is a TV dinner or like this
is a long hearty meal like an Italian
family like in The Godfather
no I pause it this way no I know the way
this guy you just need to have like a
fake confidence
so he's kind of like this all the time
they're pack let's go this side we're
gonna approach it from the outside not
from the inside like a [ __ ] rat
can you stop walking with so much
confidence
let's just be in the moment and feel
yourself genuinely you need a meditate
board bro you suck a podcast Hey
as possible
yeah like iuk or you just act like this
I think I saw that guy oh my god look we
never get to see it from the [ __ ] hey
so do you think that guy really looked
like [ __ ] neanderthal yeah
he made fun of me they say you know
you're talking about something and I was
like bored or something so I made fun of
them holy [ __ ] that's beautiful
tell you that
we're just one stop the way
and creaking okay this is definitely
create another rigger this beautiful
construction
this is for Elephants what is all this
dead space customers
Wow
she just have a cloud up there took up
space
like
crazy [ __ ] to go through [ __ ] yeah dog
yeah
[ __ ] can you stop doing that just be a
normal person okay let's go stand in the
middle and you're gonna enjoy this just
concentrate and try not to have any
physical outbursts again for no reason
hey whoa what even was that he just
really wanted to wanted to do you
[ __ ] weirdo so this part of the arch
was constructed first and then they
built it from that way that way and they
actually had a hot tub in here got
pretty hot down here
really
Campbell apartment some juice wow I mean
that's pretty cool that's sick when you
have a lot of money you have a lot of
money
yeah all this transition it is the train
station arbitration that's that must be
nice I wanted to figure it's annoying I
hope they have good windows double pane
welcome
today if he state-of-the-art right it'd
be mate of the cart
yeah that video make any sense it just
rides nothing else I yourself defend
yourself if you have to fight Friday kid
wax on wax off I was doing that she's
trying to push the toilet elbow and [ __ ]
so let's go take a look at the
chandeliers it's beautiful
PayPass so what do you think about the
report
it's very echoey
just ignore this white man
can ignore me there's a white glaze away
walking we do think that you
weird-looking person to other cultures
you know the world is a most the world
they do it like we doing it right here
right now I mean they're a lot more open
to a here this is America and we're the
land of the P stickball yeah yeah let's
go up there let's look down on it like
Lords of Winterfell
it is what it is this is a restaurant
for my [ __ ] that's what I call him
so let's just try in general to have a
[ __ ] together more and make coherent
thoughts instead of just babbling that
is what you would say you know you enjoy
being subconscious
[Music]
this is great you know what of you
it is closed for a private event
well let's go to the other side oh no
that was close
[Music]
it's a nice place to watch from you know
you seem to come here in the morning and
maybe guys yeah machine-gun fire is
quite deadly at this right yeah but
maybe like you know
hey you're a white guy wearing a green
beret scarf can you please stop talking
about assault weapons in a public space
we're already flagged right now they've
heard you do their microphones so this
is Grand Central let me just introduce
you to it it's like where a lot of
important [ __ ] happens so try not to be
disrespectful
I mean it's very circular it looks like
a it looks like a dice die it looks like
a die so here we are this is just Grand
Central that is a little bit of an upset
stomach we're trying to make do anyways
it's been a rough trip it's been in the
toilet a lot this nobody feels better
but you're a little sallow your skin's a
little pale maybe that's a good thing
for your rates don't really understand
its culture it's very abrasive but we're
making do
so what do you think ways a genuine
impression but it's alright especially
no insight it's nice to be in a lesson
[Music]
it is more peaceful
it's like the perfect melon is like it's
not too full 18 anyone's a female
without the work their race or last you
brought us on a tree follow the tracks
there's trees here this is the middle of
New York New York or like Yonkers okay
well that's a great story gonna hear an
awesome story yeah I took acid once then
I got beat up by the cops know for being
rambunctious general messy they hit me
pretty hard
I got reso Milos's where your kidney
function all the muscles breaking down
because they're exerted so hard the
occasion and they did it over and over
again
I said I'm Daniel Cormier I'm fighting
John Jim I said oh look flashy lights
and then they touch my pants and like
what was that
and then they to the ground and they
tugged on my handcuffs they like yanked
on it and I still got scars from it do
you see that that's the scar from the
handcuffs right there you got some on
this side
they started my wrist man the police
[ __ ] the police coming straight from the
underground you think that police abuse
of power is a real problem or what
[Music]
[Music]
seems like police are a special problem
that's happening over over again I think
America has the police problem I think
it's because we're taught to be the best
center jobs you got to be the best cop
and so they're like Rambo II you know I
[Music]
think our society is very unhealthy and
we teach unhealthy values and those
unhealthy values get taught to cops too
and then the cops have an Elsi values
but it's because were the cops - okay
let's explore different parts of Grand
Central
because right now
are doing monkey noises and I think that
means you're not paying attention dude
there's a robot making trying for help
noise let's go reverse that's a a gear
on the car where you go backwards and
when that happens you put on a beeping
noise okay to shoot it someone is behind
you oh let's go to this way so that's
what noise they play so that if
that's awesome I'm glad you're really
exploring yourself
[Music]
it's pretty good I'd said it tastes like
Grand Central
yeah oh hey look let's make a phone call
yo 50 Cent's local cost times where you
just need to make a call that time is
now
yes I'd like to order the
Deluxe she's comedy
so here we are it's a great place to be
we've got a fresh break hurry they got
an escalator a new a transit museum it's
closed let's just go down and have a
good time what is life even really about
we got police coming up
torch of people's
just go out there and try to
I mean it's all in
the game
look at it this is just so great we live
in America and in America we have places
like this what is this
who Emma who is he is he gay
I think so boys you're I mean you're gay
so which fireman had the best body doing
all for your chances of being straight
[Music]
just ended
[Music]
I mean here we are at the oyster bar
restaurant great restaurant
this should check it out widow
so what is your favorite GrandCentral
memory that you have this wonderful
Terminal one time I came in here I'd say
cage whoa that's a racket they said
racquetball so you can see it like a
fishbowl
yeah Wow so you thought they heard who
is he made music playing racquetball
Grand Central is anyone like really good
at talent so you go to Grant's if you
get some yeah say you're in just take me
air time you're just chilling out
watching some racquetball
I mean Grand Central is full
crazy experiences like that because New
Yorkers they're very imaginative but
they're not afraid to dream they're not
afraid to have a good time because they
do inventive pranks all the time like
have you seen Improv Everywhere
loves Pat Barry he does Pat Smith
especially it seems to me that quick
quippy remark right there
so I mean I applaud you and I think it's
great that you did that but I think
maybe next time you shouldn't laugh at
your own jokes and maybe have a good
time in other ways oh here we are again
boring old Grand Central when I go home
it's just a place full of opportunities
we go to work on come on right now
five-run 49:44 12112 actually can
Stover planes that's in Connecticut
first up southeast 21 track 157 1220
track 20 proton Harmon don't forget
don't forget Croton Harmon Yankee East 1
53rd Street first stop you know
the Yankee Stadium scene remember who
the Yankees are
[Music]
so this 42nd Street we could just hop on
it get on the 7 and get that [ __ ] out of
Dodge
do you have unlimited swiping
great that means this trip con $0 New
York is not my thing because I paid one
hundred and twenty seven dollars yeah I
just went
know it that's the price of a it just
gone up hey we were already on this side
let's go to this side let's just explore
the different sides of Grand Central
you want to interview someone
okay let's do it first person who looks
interviewer well I'm gonna interview the
[ __ ] out of them
okay are you ready it's like [ __ ]
interview someone dude no
you know here's the thing is that most
people are living stupid pointless lives
and if I bother them then it would be
actually better hey don't touch that it
actually better for them because then
their life would be filled with
significance because I have visited upon
it Wow I mean there's just so much going
on
we discover what who we are supposed to
be by seizing the opportunities because
we have this idea in our mind already
that we need to interview someone so we
didn't just make that happen if we
believe in it in us
and I believe in it I know you don't but
I have more belief and I'm better at
this than you are thank you
Wow that's not deep that's something
that's not be so when you say it at that
context
well it's better than your strategy of
just being a mopey and depressed and
saddened take it you dick hard anymore
you can't get your dick hard bro it's
just too sad all the time dude I I am
NOT excited the press as you are I have
less moments where it feels like my
penis is very small yeah so I feel like
my dick can get harder than your dick
and it's all about competition baby you
just want to be better than other people
that's all it takes
there we are
Grand Central beautiful streets
yeah exactly this joke stupid joke right
watching all these guys
yeah yeah I just saw something on Dyson
I'll just roll back their grades brick
right
and it said I'm the big girl all alone I
had Wake Tech yeah
because there's stupider in that realm
[Music]
so I mean why are there less women in
technology I think it's because a little
vaginas I think good I think their
brains are different I think they're
made more for emotional [ __ ] emotional
intelligence continue to have a baby and
take care of it a need certain hardware
I do
take care and have that deep bond with a
baby so I think men are better at this
associating with reality and thinking of
everything as a game and I think math is
just a game that you can get good at so
I think that's what happened
[Music]
I mean it's all a matter of perspective
really if you think about it with your
mind
yeah I don't know
so what do you think about this long-ass
podcast I wonder where the [ __ ] were
going
look at us we're just walking around I
mean this is a fascinating for you but
for someone else they would never be
here I'm gonna release this on
soundcloud and watch my soundcloud
rapper mentions quadrupole sometimes wow
those physical contact yeah you could
totally just side sight turn
let's make a right turn no cuz I want to
go home
the reason is cuz I want to go home
because there's a mic there yeah so
let's go to that but also keep the joy
in our hearts
it's important to remember to be
positive because I know you you forget a
lot and sometimes you get a little too
negative for my taste
hey I'm sorry that I'm smiling at you
you know sometimes I feel like I need to
stop being my what I think my dad wants
me to be
it's like a really sensitive boy
I mean do you think I'm cute oh the
truth
I mean why what did you okay that's the
Chrysler Building
oh yeah Howard Hughes he was played by
Leonardo DiCaprio and he so he ate in
bottles and he said on the airline TWA
Trane's well not everything is about
trans persons you [ __ ] snowflake Huck
hey let's go down the spinner ooh
No can you try harder
dude this guy's so weak can't even go to
go to a goddamn door this [ __ ] pansy
ass [ __ ] I am here we who are
about to die salute you
look at it it's so beautiful stop
checking to see if people are doing it
correctly and just get by with your own
skin on your bones
can you stop making noise for no reason
at all just because you need to feel
like you exist
that's not true we got to the bottom of
a lot of things it starts comedy the
heart of doing nothing the art of doing
nothing because most of life is nothing
and if you can have fun with a zero
material then most of your life is going
to be fun
all right I mean I'm just making you
good you know what I want to do
yeah dog you know what I want to do
I mean it could happen
I get more [ __ ] than you do I know
right and I live in my car sometimes I
don't tell anyone
oh Jesus I'll punch in my phone
Jesus Christ where did you learn your
manners white people school yeah you're
nothing compared to an Asian
[Music]
sorry
you're rude you have no sense of a
higher realm other than the physical you
lack social accoutrements
accoutrements
it means extra fluffer ease extra
doodads
I got cocky
rectum
there
can you even believe that we're here on
this day at this place
we're walking towards home dude what is
going on in this city
shall we take the escalator that's
I mean they're built for walking down
escalators are built so you can stand on
them but here's the thing is that stairs
are built for little old lady legs and
not for big strongman legs like I have
so maybe escalators have more form
fitting for a person with the kind of
quads that I have
[Music]
but it is just a matter of respect